waking up after you've had a full nights
of sleep
getting eight hours seven to eight hours
is crucial
for my success most people go through
life
using up a very very small part of their
potential
pay attention to the energy when you're
around somebody
and you leave them do you feel better or
worse about yourself
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey tim and carl michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn 10 successful habits that
you
can copy today enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one get enough
sleep with lewis house waking up after
you've had a full
nights of sleep getting eight hours
seven to eight hours
is crucial for my success and just a few
nights ago i was up
until three a.m for a specific reason i
was working late
and i got maybe four or five hours of
sleep and i could
feel it throughout the next day whether
i'm just getting older
and you know i'm not 21 anymore and i
can't pull all-nighters like i used to
in college
or whether i'm just doing so much more
during my days
i'm physically exerting myself i'm
mentally and emotionally asserting
myself
my body and my mind means time to
recover
from dr daniel amen who talks about the
brain and the science of the brain your
body and your brain
needs to recover you need sleep and you
need
restful sleep shawn stevenson talks
about this as well
in interviews i've done with him about
sleeping and how it's so crucial and you
can't really make
up the debt of missing out on sleep
say you get three hours a night for
weeks and months
it's going to be hard on your mind and
body it's hard to make up that
debt that you've accumulated from not
putting in the time in the hours from
the longevity experts that i've had on
and those talking about anti-aging
they all say sleep is one of the key
ingredients to success in living longer
in living healthier happier so focus on
sleep now when i was younger
in my 20s i used to think that sleep is
for those who
are broke sleep is you can sleep when
you're dead
but i'm telling you you're going to be
be dying a lot
sooner if you don't sleep well
consistently
and the brain the heart the body
everything needs time to recover
and this is when you're sleeping your
body is regenerating so if you are
putting in
uh you know hours of training or
emotional and stressful
and mental exertion throughout the day
i'm telling you your body and your mind
needs time to cleanse itself
this is when you burn fat this is when
you recover this is when
ideas start to connect but if you're not
sleeping and resting
well it's going to be extremely hard to
perform better the next day so this
isn't this isn't just for
someone that wants to live longer and
happier this is for if you want to be a
high performer as well
and have clarity and focus and energy
and not have mental stress
the brain and the body needs to sleep
habit number two
invest in yourself with warren buffett i
invest as much in myself
as you can i mean you're your own
biggest asset by far i mean you've got
you've got all kinds of potential all
the people in this room
you know you're lucky to be in this
country gotten a good education
but most people go through life using up
a very
very small part of their potential and
so anything you do that
invests in yourself
is that's the best investment you can
possibly make habit number three
work hard with muhammad ali i can earn
enough money in five years if i invested
and put it up right
to take care of my grandchildren so i
wanted to retire but after i see these
children coming
and after i see that they gonna have a
hard time maybe they won't be blessed to
make it like myself
i can knock out blue louis i can go
knock out floyd patterson i can knock
out joe frazier
i can come back and knock out you and if
you get your irish champion come knock
him out
then i'll go back over and knock
somebody didn't get too much of a laugh
on that dude
i agree so what i'm trying to say if i
can save off about
two million dollars which is about how
many pounds
i mean that's almost a million pounds
almost a million if i say
one million pounds then i can
relax and go to sleep and retire and
don't have to worry about my children
cause this is a hard world don't nobody
give you nothing you have to work for it
right right so i'm gonna try i'm blessed
to be able to beat up everybody
so i want to beat up everybody until i
can't beat them no more if i can go 10
more years
i'm going to keep on doing it habit
number four develop
discipline with tom bilyeu it was about
15 years ago i had this sense that i was
stuck in the matrix that my life could
be something more but i know how to make
it more right and part of that was
on a day when i wanted to stay in bed
when i was warm i did
and then time just feels like it's
getting away from you and you haven't
really identified that the the problem
was
that you didn't have something specific
enough to get you out of bed right you
weren't setting goals you didn't have a
vision you weren't
executing on your dreams you might be
dreaming like i was dreaming i've always
dreamed
uh for me ambition was never the problem
i was the most ambitious
laziest person you're ever going to meet
15 years ago and it was realizing wait
just because i'm lazy by nature doesn't
mean i have to be lazy in actuality like
i can actually get the discipline
to develop real drive to acquire those
skills so uh when i met the guys that
are now my partners
they put me into a scenario where there
was a very real
world consequence both positive and
negative for
living up to um the acquisition of
skills
so and and that environment that
gladiator pit that i ended up stepping
into was the business world
and the great thing is when you're no
longer an employee and it's your
business and everything you have is on
the line and if the business fails you
lose your house like that
that's real yeah it's real to you in a
way that it's not to an employee right
because now
there's a real consequence that goes
beyond well i have to look for another
job right this goes into
i could lose everything if i can't solve
this problem now that
can scare you away and keep you wanting
to be an employee where it's a little
bit safer
or that can be wildly motivating to you
and that was interesting to me so
i wanted to be able to say the harder i
work the better result i get and they
gave me the opportunity to plug into
business where that became true
if i could solve these problems if i
could build a better product if i could
market it better whatever
that better results came and so there
was like now a connection between how
hard i work
the skills i acquire and the reward i
get and that that was all i needed
what's up everybody i want to talk about
the amazing book by evan carmichael
built
to serve i want to read you guys a
section this is from
a part under the heading of your pain is
your strength this is the fundamental
mind shift that most people
never make but is required for success
the pain that you went through
that you're trying to forget it's your
strength
it's the way through it's your answer
that pain is how you become the tree
you've experienced the pain grow from it
and are stronger now and are able to
help others who need
the support so there it is your pain
is the very thing that's going to get
you through it's kind of like what ryan
holliday says the obstacle
is the way all right guys check it out
build to serve by evan carmichael who
can teach a master class on how to be a
badass and be good to people
dude is rad check out his book a lot of
amazing stuff in there
how about number five forgive with john
paul de jouria
anyone that you want to let's say uh uh
go against anybody you don't like
anybody that's as pleased as you anybody
you want revenge for anybody that you
hate
anything you remember that someone did
bad to you let it go
forgive them you don't have to say it
out loud you can say to yourself
i forgive you people you really really
hate
it's amazing what happens amazing
something lifts off your shoulder and
the negative
isn't as strong as it was before this is
amazing thing that cost
absolutely nothing i cannot change
yesterday's newspaper
i'm not going to let it burn me down
because by being in my subconscious
mind everything around me looks bleaker
because i had this bad stuff
happen to me before that i want a
revenge or that i hate it's still
in that subconscious mind get it out of
there
get it out there by saying i forgive you
no matter how bad they work
i forgive you no matter how much revenge
you want i forgive you no matter how
just it is
or injustice i forgive you it lifts the
burden off you
so when these little things start
happening and they're little things now
but they're actually gigantic to you now
in the future you would have gone
through it it would have been smaller
but one way to make it smaller now is
get off your shoulder out of your mind
all that disrespect all that hate all
that revenge all that jealousy
get them out of there forgive everybody
for just forgive them habit number six
stop procrastinating with miles monroe
my greatest fear tonight is very simple
and that is i am afraid that most of you
in this room and in this auditorium
tonight
and perhaps watching this program you
are going to
add to the treasure and the wealth of
the cemetery
and that makes me very sad because
buried inside of you
are dreams that you still carry it ideas
that god planted in your heart
that you still haven't done yet
paintings that you've been planning to
paint and
books you've been thinking about writing
and paintings you keep procrastinating
about
and what i'm so concerned about is we'll
never see your painting
we'll never sing a song we'll never read
your book and we'll never
operate in your business and we never
experience the invention that you keep
procrastinating on
i trust that you will rob the graveyard
of your treasure yes i pray that you
will disappoint the cemetery
i pray that when the the mall gets your
carcass
it'll be empty habit number seven take
small actions with marissa peer take
action
every day in the direction of your goals
no matter how small
the action is the smallness doesn't
matter
what matters is you are wiring your mind
coding your mind firing into your mind
the habits of
natural winners and then you'll be a
winner
and who cares if it's unnatural that's
not important
habit number eight overcome doubt with
brendan burchard
doubts should not win anymore mondays
tuesdays wednesdays thursday fridays
anymore there's no more part of you that
doesn't say
you know what i have all the opportunity
in the world turn the person up shaking
say
all the opportunity in the world
[Applause]
i don't think i'm ready for this if you
ever hear that in your brain
stop that that is fear that it's
insecurity that is doubt and you are
above
that you are above that you have passed
that you've gone so far beyond that
and you went beyond that years ago if
you recognize your truth and your
strength
because to be here you went beyond that
years ago but you haven't stepped fully
into it
you passed the doubt a long time ago but
you're still letting it win some days
you pass the parts of you that says
let's go slow here
let's be cautious here because you know
someone might make fun of me or it might
not turn out well
listen you you have so much ability to
pivot like this
so why not go for big things
if you can in a modern era if we can
pivot this fast because of technology
tools teams outsourcing fiverr
i mean because we have all these things
you can pivot
literally on the daily so why not commit
to something big
and go for it the issue is most people
they'll dabble they'll go okay i'll go
for a little bit but because they can't
pivot they pivot too soon
without ever having fully committed to
something with boldness in their heart
and when i'm in the mountains i'm like
whoa the fire comes back in
the boldness comes back in delay doesn't
win action wins
doubt does not win fire wins
division from other people uh-uh i don't
feel divided from i don't go oh those
people i can't be like them i go you
know what one day
i will celebrate among them and then one
day i will lead
why because we're all called to that
the hardest challenge in our entire
lives will be recognizing a calling to a
higher level of leadership
i really believe when ethan talks about
the soulful strategies so much of that
is that sense of us that says you know
what i i do feel something inside that
is
urging me or begging me on to
strategically choose something that
maybe is beyond my reach right now but
will give me
a beyond level of service too
there's a leadership level in your
hearts here it's easy to forget
there's a leadership level that's asking
you to not only be among
the greats but to also
get there help them and lead them one
day
now why does that sound so scary for us
to say
because we go oh who am i right i who am
i
i never i never looked at when i was
looked up but dean and tony and wayne
dyer and
marianne williams and deepak chopra i
never thought i couldn't hang out with
them
maybe it's because i had the blessings
of growing up in montana and
environments like this where we all hung
out we had picnics all the time
right the people with big fancy houses
went to the same park where i grew up
so we all had one big park we all went
there the fancy people are there we're
there no problem
we all had a cooler vice i'm big no big
deal maybe i got
that blessing of the mixing and mingling
when i was young but i didn't think that
they were super human or super gods or
anything else like that
and some of you you're comparing
yourselves to each other in here
yesterday someone told me that and it's
like well you know this person's
i don't know if i'm experienced enough
yet for this group my experience
so when would you be experienced to
network and mingle with awesome people
when does that day come for you
that you finally get to work with the
people that you want to when does that
day come that you share the bigger
dreams when does that day come you go
home and you crush it
when does the day finally come i'm just
here to say
we're in the mountains i'm talking about
motivation manifest so you might as well
make a declaration and make this day
that you say
i commit to more boldness in my life i'm
ready to go
no more doubts no more delaying no more
i'm not good enough or i'm not ready if
it's like no
if you joined a group like that that was
a bold and a swift movement to commit to
to honor
and to really utilize take that next
step
do that next big thing whatever that
fire that came in that said you know
what i'm going to do this even if you're
unsure about being here
do not let your insecurity win here
habit number nine
stay positive with randy jackson
everything in life is relative
so guess what change your mind your body
your spirit your outlook your thinking
you get more positive you get way more
energy
you want to do more things you're
thinking more clearly
it helps every part of your life it's
like what the doctors used to say
a well-balanced diet with diet and
exercise
proper amount of sleep taking care of
your body wow
it does wonders and habit number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips
is pursue excellence with robin sharma
the great ones all have one thing in
common
they are mono maniacal perfectionists
they have
a wild obsession with the pursuit of
excellence
and so you see the great artists and the
great business people
and the great chefs i was recently at
the test kitchen
in cape town and i had a just a
absolutely world-class meal and i thank
luke the chef and the whole team over
there for delivering
just a a wizard like a magical
experience at the test kitchen in cape
town and it was just
the quality of the food and the user
experience and now
they've got two rooms there's the dark
room you walk in and there's the dark
room
where you experience the beginning parts
of the meal i think four courses or five
courses
and they pull out this map and they say
you're going to start off here and then
you're going to go here and then we're
going to take you in terms of the food
here and you're going to end it here
and it's just this really it's it's a
a sensational experience and a
thoughtful experience and a creative
experience and uh
just a magical experience and then after
you finish that they walk you into the
lightroom where you try
all of this different these different
plates and
they pair it with with exquisite what
they call iconic wine and it's just the
service is dialed in and you watch the
kitchen and it's
all i'm trying to say is i love hotels
that are obsessively attentive to detail
i love restaurants where the smallest
flour on a piece of food or
the way the music is set up or the
smallest attention
and refinement or innovation is so well
thought through in a world
that embraces mediocrity in a world
where so few people see themselves as
artists in a world where
many people who are good people are just
checked out and there's no
fire in the belly to innovate and create
painstaking care about what they do
i i want to remind you of the importance
of
being obsessively attentive to the
smallest of details
because that's what artists do now i've
got a really special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through
on your goals 35 that's not enough
that's not enough just to get motivated
believe nation we're here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through
when you write it down you have a 91
chance of following through
and when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95
chance from 30 something percent to 95
chance of you following through
believe nation we need to make this
happen so question of the day
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action specific
for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
collect
good people get into the habit of
collecting good people
what that means is when you find
somebody who you
you hang out with you spend a little bit
of time with and you feel better about
yourself
you have more energy you're more
inspired you want to go home and do more
work and build a better life
when you're around those people even for
a moment
try to find a way to spend more time
with them
most of the people in our lives uh
they're takers not because they're bad
people or they're
they're only intake or mentality they're
just they're in a lot of pain they're
struggling a lot
you're probably ahead of where they are
you're the person who's giving them
the motivation the energy the belief the
hope you're the one who's the most
ambitious person in your circle
and so you're pushing the people around
you to do better you're that person for
other people
but who is that person for you and
chances are you don't have that person
in your life
and so maybe you get it from books or
from videos uh
maybe online communities but you don't
have that person in your life
and that's what we need to start to
cultivate and so when you find somebody
around you even if you haven't spent a
lot of time with them
when you feel them it's super important
to pay attention to the energy
pay attention to the energy when you're
around somebody
and you leave them do you feel better or
worse about yourself
do you have more energy more
vitalization
more hope more inspiration or do you
feel drained
do you feel low energy do you feel
lethargic do you feel like you need a
break
was it too overwhelming and again most
of the people in our lives are the ones
who drain us
because they're in a lot of pain and it
takes us a lot of energy to
to help them or to try to just deal with
them
i look at zandaman as an example in my
community so
zandaman uh is a confidence coach he
is now my co-host on my gaming channel
where we answer people's questions live
and he was one of the first people
inside my mover makers program
and zen just had so much energy when you
hang around with zen
you feel better you feel more energetic
you feel more hopeful you feel more
inspired
and so when i started movement makers
he was one of the first people in and
now before i come on so
like in the 10 to 15 minutes before
movement maker starts
zayn's on playing music says hey zayn
you used to be dj
do you want to do you want to do a
little pre-show
welcome people to movement makers as
they join tell them to turn their
cameras on give them some love give them
some energy
just inject some confidence into people
it's like yeah i'd love to do that
and so he's doing that now and it's a
great value add to the people who are
in the community then i said hey do you
want to do a a gaming channel a live
gaming channel with me where you answer
questions
i'm going to play the game you you be my
co-host you bring the questions and
we'll both answer them
because i was having a hard time trying
to read the questions and play the game
at the same time
he's like yeah i'm down to do that and
so now i hang out with zen
i went from scenes and you know every
two weeks inside of movement makers
to four times a week
[Music]
four times a week when i'm answering
questions on the gaming channel
and so i'm trying to find a way to spend
more time with zane because i love the
energy
i love how i feel afterwards and i love
the
value that it also brings the community
and the people watching
so i really want you to start to think
about for your own life who are the
people around you
who make you feel more hopeful more
inspired more
positive more empowered more more
positive like who are those people
and they may not be people who you're
hanging out with a lot
right if i look at zan the man i was
only seeing him
every two weeks in a group setting
it was in the groups with there's lots
of people in there zan was one of the
people
so it's not like i was talking to him uh
for two hours every two weeks right had
minimal exposure
every two weeks in a group setting but i
singled him out it's like
i like that guy i want to find a way to
spend more time with that guy i want to
do something more
with that guy and he could have said no
to hosting or to djing
but he said yes to both and so there's
probably people who are in your
community somewhere
who you've spent some amount of time
with
that i want you to rack your brain
they're not going to be your closest
friends probably
if you do have that as your closest
friend holy cow are you blessed
uh and and be grateful and tell that
friend thank you so much
but if you don't have that person then
think about over the past six months
who has been somebody who you've met
you've hung out with
in an online setting and how can you
spend more time with them so how does
someone regain trust then because we
were talking about this earlier how do
you
regain trust and regain open
communication
if someone's been unfaithful or just
hurting them for
a couple of years in a relationship and
you feel like it's not working you know
it's interesting because you're asking
me this and yet you
as an amazing role model have spoken
about some of your own experiences of
abuse
so you know this question how do you let
someone
touch you come near you not feel like
they're gonna harm you
they understand the difference between
caring touch and hurtful touch
allowing yourself to experience pleasure
again allowing yourself to surrender
without thinking that while you're not
on guard
nothing bad is going to happen really
challenging right okay
but it's that same trajectory
right it's like you begin to
you first of all you well in this case
your child versus adult but you
you you you hope
that it's not because one person hurts
you that you lose your faith in humanity
you hope that you know that there are
people who are not harmful
that they really are good people that
care and love
you probably trust with your eyes more
open
it doesn't have the same naivety one day
i was in new york
and i was having like a really bad pms
craving for carbs
i was just like i was like mama needs
some carbs and i was feeling like a
croissant and there was this great
little french bakery
around the corner that i've never been
to and i'm like i'm gonna go get my
croissant right now
so i roll up to this little french
bakery and on the window there's like
this
handmade sign that said you know offer
vacation
back you know july 18th and it was like
this two-week thing
wow you're like what and i was like wait
wait what your business you need to be
here yes and yet there it was empty and
this simple little like hand-drawn sign
and in that moment louis
i had this notion i was like wait a
minute i'm running this digital company
i have all of these amazing beautiful
gorgeous souls that i work
with and we're producing content once a
week
every week non-stop when do we ever take
a break and the advantage for me like
josh who works in entertainment like
siri sometimes they'll have
you know you watch your favorite series
like i love handmaid's tale i love
stranger things you see 11 or 12
episodes
and wait a year and yes and then they're
off for a little while
right and i thought to myself why do i
not have down time built into my
business and this was about the time
when also
there was just a cultural uprising with
like you know hustle 24 7 and you have
to work non-stop and like
never take a break and i'll i'll sleep
when i'm dead and i'm like those are
horrible messages for your health yeah
so we decided after i saw so after i had
my
croissant craving i told my director of
operations i said
starting right now we're going to close
the company down for two weeks in the
summer
and two weeks in the winter and in
addition to people's
already having their yes their vacation
time and we started that
i guess maybe i don't know five six
years ago it might be wrong on those
dates but a good number of time ago
and so our company goes dark twice a
year
and now the company's at a place where
not everyone in customer service takes
off those exact same two weeks so they
stagger
so that we can take care of people but
everyone has two weeks of dark time
two weeks of dark time and what's great
about that is that
you don't get fomo thinking that you're
off and there's all these other things
happening and there's projects moving
ahead
and there's these things that you want
to be in on but you're like feeling that
tension because the rest of the company
is moving ahead and you're trying
to relax so it's been a game changer for
us what i love
is it's it's very it's linear it's step
by step you get up you start writing for
yourself and then you start writing
first audience of five and then you
start writing for
you know probably a large lecture
audience and it's so funny
because i think because my career has
gotten a little more visible in the last
two years people are always like oh my
god this is amazing like how this like
overnight success thing so
i started this blog what like 10 and a
half years ago
right literally the 10-year overnight
success exactly
10 and a half years ago um and
i wrote every single day for
two years before anybody just said
anything to me about anything other than
my friends
right um and one day i wrote this post
it was called don't carpe diem and again
it is a post i would have scrapped
i thought i didn't think it was good my
dad called me after my dad was my main
reader
okay i love it yes most of my feedback
is still is from my dad
he called me and he was like he went uh
about the today's
essay this freaking
essay went completely viral
and more than a million shares right and
it was like this teeny little blog
and then you know two weeks later i was
my inbox was full
of um letters from agents in new york
and
two weeks after that i was in new york
city at an auction for a book
based on the blog but the but i had
never
ever one time promoted or tried to do
anything to all i did was sit my butt
down and write
my heart out each day for the small
audience that was there
and it just organically turned into the
book and
all the wider things and that's how the
nonprofit started too finally
an entrepreneur is always positive he's
an optimist
and he proves
you know the there are lots of cynics
lots of
negative people around but an
entrepreneur spreads
positive energy that's really what i
have learned happiness has a
surprisingly bad reputation and a lot of
people feel very uncomfortable with the
idea that they would seek to be happier
sometimes this is because they feel that
in a world so full of suffering
it's not morally appropriate to seek to
be happier or they feel like well a
happy person is just complacent
sits around thinking about their own
satisfaction all the time
but in fact research shows that happy
people are
more interested in the problems of the
world happier people are more altruistic
they give away more money they volunteer
more time they're more likely to help
out if a family member or a friend
needs a hand when we're unhappy it's
very easy to become
defensive isolated and preoccupied with
our own problems but when we're happy
we have the emotional wherewithal to
turn outward and to think about other
people
and the problems of the world a man
walking on a road in a small town
found a piece of paper tied to an
electric pole
the paper had a small note written on it
and so curious to know the contents
he went closer and read what was written
there
the note read i'm a poor woman
and i've lost 50 rupees somewhere around
here on the road
if any of you happen to find it could
you kindly
bring it to me at this address due to a
very poor eyesight
i can barely see so please
help the man followed the address
and found an old dilapidated heart with
a much
older lady sitting outside
as she heard the sound of his footsteps
the lady who looked really weak
and frail asked who is it
the man replied as i was walking on the
road nearby
i found 50 rupees there and then
happened to read the note
that you put up on the electric pole so
i came over
to hand this money to you
hearing this the lady began to weep
and she said dear sir at least 30 to 40
people
have come over to give me 50 rupees
saying that they found it on the road
and that they read the note
on the electric pole well trust me i
didn't write that note
i cannot even see properly nor do i know
how to read
or write it's okay
please keep this money and get something
for yourself
said the man as he was about
to leave the lady asked him to
tear that note off on his way back
as the man walked back
he wondered about who could have
written that note and certainly
she would have asked every one of the 30
to 40 people
who had come to bring her the 50 rupees
to
tear that note but none had done it
the man mentally thanked the person
who had written the note and thought to
himself
if one truly wants to help someone in
need
and makes an attempt so many more
come forth to join the chain of kindness
and make a positive difference it takes
one person's genuine will to help
and then there is always a way
as the man was walking back his spirit
uplifted by the positive energy and the
joy of serving
another man walking by stopped him and
asked
can you help me with this addresser i
just found a
50 rupee note and want to hand it over
let us feel grateful for being blessed
with what we have
and let us try and be instrumental
in sharing even a tiny bit of what we
have
with those who are not only in need
but are utterly helpless let kindness
and love
spread in the world and let humanity
be the ruling force you know you really
should not
just perform off the audience's energy
you should just perform with your own
energy
but it's hard to always do that you know
you're gonna feed off their energy no
matter what it is
it's really the reason i can do it all
like it's it's the reward i get
you know touring and being an artist is
really really hard and it's a lot of
work so
you know the only thing that i think
makes it worth it is
performing for the people that support
you of what you make yeah i think you
know with the with technology in the
workspace i think there are no
guidelines right people
people don't set up guidelines one of
the things i talk about you know when i
work with companies
and about cultivating focus is that
there's no way to
tell um someone in the workspace
especially if you have an open floor
open plan floor plan uh that
what's your status right now so for
example do you use skype or have you
skyped with skype before
well you can set your status as offline
busy
on a call not available right and when
you see someone is offline
most of the time i think most people
will never try calling that person
if they're offline or if they're not
available or it says do not disturb you
don't try and call that person
right but in the workspace in an open
floor
open plan floor plan there's no way to
set that status
there's no way to inform so what happens
is someone is working on their computer
they might be doing accounting trying to
solve some complex accounting
issue and then someone comes up to them
and goes hey
john do you know where the photocopy
paper is
so now he goes oh it used to be in this
cupboard i think they moved it over
there
you know have a look over there he was
like oh thank you so that guy goes to
get the photocopy paper
now john goes back to his accounting
and he's lost his train of thought you
know his awareness was so deep in it
trying to solve something complex
and now his awareness moved to the
person to talk about photocopy paper and
now he comes back
and he has to try and get back to where
he was and he may not
and especially if you're doing something
creative i remember working with a
fashion company in l.a
and they said the same thing you know
they're designers sketching the fall
collection
someone comes and asks them a question
or says hi
they turn they say hello they turn back
to continue this catch and now they've
lost
their mojo they've lost their flow so
because there's no way for the person
working to tell that person what their
status is
so one simple solution i tell companies
is to
have a simple flag
like you drive on the street there's
traffic lights red means
stop orange or yellow means go faster
no prepare to stop right and green means
go
right so what if you had a little flag
on your desk
as an example it doesn't have to be a
flying but you had a little plastic flag
on you
and you say red means do not disturb me
i am immersed in something really
important
but what you do is within the department
to say if you're in the design
department or the accounting department
there's 10 people in the accounting
department all 10 people have a meeting
and we set the status as red means do
not disturb
but below it we outline the conditions
upon which you can interrupt so if the
building is on fire
yes you can disturb me and let me know
all right
if these conditions are not met don't
disturb me then if it's an orange flag
then you can say okay i'm doing
something important
but it's not super important so there's
any
if these conditions are met you can
interrupt me and if i have a green flag
means i'm just working if you want to
come by and say hello or
you want to interrupt me it's fine so
that way someone walking
will see a flag and go like oh it's a
red flag i shouldn't disturb that person
now you increase productivity and
efficiency in
in the workplace when i was young i'm
talking 10 years old
we didn't have any money i lived with my
dad maybe i was probably 11 or 12.
looked at my dad we didn't have any
money but all my friends were racing bmx
that's when bmx was
huge maybe it's still big but that's
when it first came out was exciting
and my friends were getting really nice
bikes i couldn't afford
any of those in fact i fell in love with
a bike called a hutch
there was diamondback and hutch they
were the two
best brands back then like people would
buy a mongoose it was like a lead
balloon i mean you couldn't even pick up
a mongoose at the time
but these hutch this hutch bike was all
alloy or whatever kind of metal it was
that was
so light and it was amazing so not only
did people get a hutch so i'm going and
i'm watching the bmx
uh the the bicycle motocross i'm
watching the races
and man these kids are flying and
i had a big old heavy bike and i wanted
a hutch i wanted a bike that you could
lift up with one finger but man i wasn't
even close to the money
plus i'm going to school plus i have
homework plus my dad made me do all the
chores i had to do right
so then i figured out how do i get the
money to buy a hutch now of course my
dad my grandmother i live in my dad
and some of my grandmother um they
supported me but they didn't have the
money
so i asked my grandmother if i could
clean out the garage and clean out the
basement anything i found that she
didn't want
could i sell it at a garage sale now
this is summer vacation right
so get into summer vacation and i find
all kinds of stuff that she's like oh
i'm not gonna use that for years i don't
want that i throw that out anyway
and then i asked my grandmother if i
could do that in her friend's garages
and basement so i went to her friend
evelyn
oh my god i found so much great stuff so
i went to three different places
i accumulated all this stuff and i did a
garage sale
every weekend on the front yard of my
grandmother's house i'd walk like a half
a mile to the main highway
main highway for a little town i'd i'd
pound in a sign
yard sale and i sat there and i learned
how to sell because people would come
there'd be five bucks on something
i give you two like oh i don't want two
fives better but
how about four how about three 350. so
i'm negotiating week after week so i do
about four weeks and i make like 250
maybe
300 bucks my dad reminded me of this
story but i remember was a lot i'd say
like a gazillion dollars
but guess what a hutch bike at the time
just the frame was like 400 bucks
then you had to buy the alloy wheels i
wanted the skinny ones
if you know anything about it was just i
wanted the skinny wheels then i wanted
shimano
shimano pedals and i wanted the better
ball
bearings and i wanted this cool little
uno seat i think it was called the uni
uni seat or uno seat or whatever it's
cool little plastic seat i mean this
thing was going to be so light
and 250 or 300 bucks wasn't enough i'm
like wow so now i'm heading back to
school
my dad at the time owns a collision shop
but he also used to buy he'd go to
uh uh auctions where if you got a car
accident and your car was wrecked and it
was totaled or just
stolen recovery it would go to these uh
auctions
that my dad would go to and he'd buy a
car that was wrecked but not two wrecked
and fix it up and he'd sell it
so i said to my dad hey can i buy a car
can i buy a car for 250 bucks and then
i'll fix it on my time and i'll pay you
for literally i said
i'll fix it on my time my dad's like
yeah you'll pay if you do that you got
to pay for all the expenses all the
parts yourself
so i'm like cool so now i'm back in
school i give my dad
the 250 300 bucks and he goes and buys a
mercury capri now i'd love to say the
day
the year but it wasn't even the 80s it
was probably like a late
70s car um now it's probably an 80s i
don't know
late 70s 80s and it was a capri and i
had already
been working with my dad since i was a
little kid working on cars so i knew
cars
and he didn't help me much at all he
even said that he was i
i let you struggle and gotta i learned
that parenting style for my dad i wanna
i hope i'm doing a good enough job
with my kids because my dad didn't have
the money he didn't have the time he had
a hustle so he's like you want to wreck
i'll buy it for you but you're paying
all the fees and you got to work on it
so every day i could after school now
i'm still going to school still doing my
homework still doing my chores right
install my regular gig
but every day after school that i could
i'd go work on this capri and i remember
as a first time i wrecked my knuckles so
bad
trying to get a bolt off that i couldn't
it slipped and it scraped on the other
ones
i'd go to school my hands greasy and
knuckles beat up
but i worked on that i probably could
have been done in a week and it probably
took me three months
and when i got to the painting part i
remember i paid the guy that worked for
my dad to come in on a weekend and paint
it
because i didn't know how to paint back
then long story short i get the car done
i sell it and i profited 900 bucks
so i took 250 rolled it over into a
wrecked car
redid the car and i made 900.
and i went and bought my hutch bike i
bought the pedals i bought the ball
bearings i bought these cool little
alloy wheels that were really thin i
bought the thin little tires
i bought the uni seat i bought these
cool handlebars
i even bought some some gear to work out
in
and i got my bike now was i ever good at
racing bmx
oh i sucked i was a little i'd go week
after week and get my ass kicked i got
think i think i got
two trophies in probably a whole two
seasons
but i loved it and i wanted to go every
single week and i
i loved this bike so much because i
earned every ounce of that bike
every inch of that bike i fought for i
paid for it
but how does that relate to you because
in life we think there's these magical
ways these
quick ways these shortcuts to wealth we
think there's these shortcuts to get the
things that we want our
our new hutch it might be your house
might be the car might be
freedom but we want the shortcuts listen
at a
at a young age i was going to school
that was my day job i still had to do it
i did homework i did my chores all my
responsibilities i still had to do
while simultaneously every moment i
could i squeezed into
garage sale and then um and then working
on this car
to see that there's no magic money
machine you still got to do the yard
sale
while you do your homework you still got
to fix the car this is metaphorically
while you're doing your chores and going
to school
but the end result is i got what i
wanted with a little bit of extra hustle
but that momentum carried my whole life
when i was in the collision business i
worked on my real estate business
but i had to go work on cars every day
and finally got real estate making money
and then i'm in the real estate business
i wanted to teach others so i was still
working on real estate every day but i'd
work at night creating courses and
programs
and then when i was doing i wanted to go
to live events i still worked on course
and programs while i worked on my live
event business
i still had to hustle i still had to
find enthusiasm i still had to be
excited
i still had to get things done and i
still had to pay the bills
going to school doing homework doing
chores is the same as
working in a collision shop while i'm
working in my dream of real estate
working on my
dream of impacting other people while
i'm still working on real estate
play to your own element don't try and
perform someone else's
expertly so in modern terminology how
would i say that
is don't waste your time steve jobs
don't waste your time
trying to live someone else's life you
know don't be trapped by dogma
focus in on your own strengths your own
element what you have to offer
don't get lost in trying to become like
someone else or
pretend to be someone else there's a
beautiful
one of my favorite quotes by einstein
and then steve jobs again einstein said
if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree it will spend its whole
life believing that it's stupid
and too many of us are fish trying to
climb a tree
too many of us are monkeys being taught
how to swim too many of us are lions
being taught to live like cats
we're not getting to live in our element
so my second piece of advice is live
in that element that you've naturally
been given don't try adopt another
you know we've all got a special genius
inside of us it was steve wozniak and
steve jobs this conversation
steve wozniak looked steve wozniak for
those who don't know is the tech
guy behind apple he practically invented
the technology and the software and
everything
so steve wozniak looked at steve jobs
and he says this is in walter isaacson's
biography of steve jobs steve wozniak
wozniak looks at steve jobs and he says
what do you even do he said you're not a
coder you're not a designer
you're not a marketer and you're not an
engineer what do you even do
imagine challenging steve jobs and steve
jobs replies he says
he says musicians play their instruments
i play the orchestra
that is the most deep understanding of
one's role in life
and not getting lost in other people's
identities and perceptions of you
steve jobs knew that he wasn't a
marketer he wasn't an engineer he wasn't
a coder
so he hired all of those but he played
the orchestra he brought it all together
and that's when you when you find
confidence in your own role you won't be
envious of anyone else
my mother has the most amazing and
uncanny ability
to decipher what matters from what
doesn't very quickly
and then she would go through this thing
where she would iteratively tell you all
the time
this is what's important this is what's
not this is what's important this is
what's not
so sooner or later you begin to know how
to do it yourself
uh do you know what i mean it becomes
like you know your own second your
default settings
exactly yeah exactly you know like um
um i've got soccer boots i don't have
shin guards
go go do this thing right and it's um i
i
it it's just been it's it's been a big
lesson for me that i've learned from
omar which is
just decipher what matters from what
doesn't and focus on what matters
because
sooner or later society will forget the
other stuff it moves on it's trends
anyway and
it'll pass and then you'll live the life
you've wanted to live invariably
if we teach a person then how to trade
that frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say
yeah but you know it was my ex's fault
or i got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah yeah we
know that okay so let's take your
partner in business or take your ex
let's duct tape them put them in a
cannon and shoot them to the moon
now what are you going to do sooner or
later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right
so then teach a person then how to trade
that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude
as an example yes the person says well i
can't feel gratitude and i say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration
so now it's going to take a little time
to cause that heart of you to bloom or
your heart of yours to bloom
once they're able to feel even the
smallest measure of gratitude where they
start feeling
appreciation thankfulness gratitude
it's emotional signature when you when
you get something
when you're receiving something when
something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened
where it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude
well that emotion then is telling the
body that the experience has already
occurred
and the thought then can make it into
the body because it's consistent with
the thought
so now you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system
into a very specific destiny you got to
maintain that modified state of mind and
body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time
and if you can get ready because
something weird or unusual some
synchronicity some coincidence
some opportunity is going to land in
your lap and you didn't have to go and
get it
yes it came to you now you're the vortex
of creation so if you say to me
well i was feeling gratitude but then
there was traffic or my co-worker sent
me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment
to control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it
but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did inside of you and you're going
to believe more that you're the creator
of your life and less of the victim of
your life
every level of success that you want to
achieve
in health wealth relationships career
business etc
requires a new understanding
of a skill and a new behavioral pattern
what got you to where you are is
not enough to get you to where you want
to go
why do i say that because if it was
enough to get you to where you want to
go
you would already be there
so what got you here will not get you
there maybe some stepping stones
but every level of success
requires a new level of
skill and behavior and i'm going to go
back to one of the other lessons
since we develop beliefs and habits
and behaviors that go from conscious
effort
to non-conscious habits in order to
achieve the next level of success
you have to learn how to create new
habits of thought
new emotional management skills and new
behaviors to
match the level of success that you want
to achieve
well the simple part that most people
don't understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts
go out into the universe and are
accepted
and brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought
and every time you speak a word you are
literally
painting your future making your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware of what you
don't want in your life and how you are
contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some
reason in the last 20 years the universe
has wanted
this to go out among all the people or
all the people that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do
to begin to train yourself to be aware
of what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin
on the smallest level to be aware of our
thinking
we can start to make changes you know
that um
wave that you feel or your tongue gets
numb or you get tightness in your cheeks
or you freeze you know when that happens
based on the science there is only a
90-second chemical release in your body
it's called the 90-second rule
when your body starts to stomach starts
to flutter when your heart starts to
race
when you feel this feeling of fear that
you have that's unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
rule and
all of the chemical release that's
happening because your body is going
into a state of being alert
it only sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation so
the next time that your body
goes into a state of alert stomach gets
tight you feel frozen
you get stuck you feel your neck when
the body starts to do that
number one just remember
it means your body is getting ready to
be alert and pay attention doesn't and
it does not mean you're going to lose
control it does not mean you're in
danger it does not mean to stop or to
shut up
i want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it
and realize that the hormones that just
got released because you're about to do
something
they only last 90 seconds that's it you
can breathe slowly you can
count to 90. you can get up and walk
around you can do 90 seconds of jumping
jacks
you can meditate for 90 seconds you can
ground your feet in your chair
and wiggle a minute so that you feel
your body in your chair
and take deep breaths and what you're
going to
find is that you're going to be blown
away
you're going to be blown away because
what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat you can go from being
somebody
who has an upset stomach and who would
normally not go talk to your boss who
would
normally not walk into that gym who
would normally
not make that call in 90 seconds flat
you can manipulate your body state to
calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up and now you can show up is
there anything that you wish you uh
didn't do yes
i wish i had not waited 14 years
somebody said if you want to lose
something lose
money you can get that back 8 out of 10
millionaires have been financially
bankrupt walt disney filed bankruptcy
seven times
had two nervous breakdowns but don't
lose time
there were 14 years i sat on the
sideline
14 years i said i don't have an investor
in me like tony robbins 14 years that
said
i don't have an mba or a phd and i can't
compete with these guys i have the
complexion of rejection
14 years i silenced myself wow
and so i regret that because there are
some people that
maybe if they'd heard my voice
they would not have turned to drugs if
they'd heard my
voice their lives would have taken a
different direction
and i can't get those 14 years back
that haunts me and may i think that
drives me when i speak
with such energy i'm trying to make up
for that time
but i can't do you think one of the edge
you had over everybody else was
the biggest percentage of your focus was
on one thing
do you see it that way like that was my
edge over everybody else
i do um at the time i didn't really
understand that
right so you know basketball for me was
the most important thing so everything i
saw
whether it was tv shows whether it was
books i read
people i talked to everything was done
to try to learn how to become
a better basketball player everything
everything and so when you have like
right now
i mean it's got to be crazy right now i
leave here and i fly out to oregon
and i'll be in oregon with uh cameron
haynes we'll be getting out there for a
few days
a lot more podcasts a lot more
interviews but every day every morning i
get up
i still get my run in every morning how
do you structure the training
the training is basically structured off
of my schedule so look at my schedule
and i said okay um jennifer what do we
have today
we have this at seven o'clock in the
morning roger that
that means i gotta be up by four o'clock
in the morning to run that's how it
works
that's how all my [ __ ] works so she lays
out the schedule of events
two out you just you just set it two
hours earlier she says it could take an
hour to get to rich rolls
let's say we were at seven o'clock today
in the morning it takes an hour to get
to rich rolls with no traffic okay let's
let's block into hour 15 for rich roll
okay we got that the morning time i'm
gonna run
seven miles this morning i need uh 52
30 for that roger that put in [ __ ]
shower shave
add that in so the schedule dictates
but i have always just push it back
right so
that means getting up at 1 30. trust me
roger that i've done that several times
yeah
several how much sleep do you usually
get i i like
getting seven to eight hours of sleep
nowadays i can do that
but there's times where the schedule
says hey man you're getting three hours
and if that's the case
right merry christmas that first hour of
every day is very very precious
you should think about how you can
invest that wisely for some maybe you
want to do something like
reading in the morning for some maybe
you want to do a little bit of exercise
you want to work out you want to do a
little bit yoga a little bit of
stretching for some you want to have
a very nice breakfast with your
family it is connection time for some
maybe it's time for you to set the goals
and say okay what are some of the things
that you want to accomplish
that particular day what you don't want
is to jump into
email mode i always say your inbox is
other people's agenda
every single time you check your inboxes
all these things that
just demands your attention that pulls
your way
that distracts you you don't want to
check your emails 10 times a day
and you don't want to check your social
media 10 20 times a day either
it's very easy to screen suck all day
and you're checking messages
checking messages repetitively right and
you check it every 10
20 minutes do you really need to do that
the metaphor i use all the time is do
you go check your mailbox
10 20 times a day then why would you go
check your inbox 10-20 times a day
one of the things i do is i block out
the time for social media and i block
out time
for email that's it i have a
start time i have an end time i don't go
check social media 10 20 times a day
because
i've got other things to do i've got
more important things
i have to accomplish if you could go
back and talk to your
younger self go build the time machine
and go back and talk to your younger
self
what what advice would you give the
younger you that maybe you didn't
realize about yourself
that you wish you did when you were
younger well the first thing that pops
into my mind is that he shows up
he shows up he shows up and i think he's
sitting in the audience here
but i spent a lot of time as a younger
self worrying about
am i going to meet the right one am i
going to be able to have children am i
going to start a family and i would tell
my younger self just chill out he shows
up
just do your thing don't spend any
mental energy on that but it's hard you
know especially as a woman
i really wanted to be financially
independent i wanted to chart my own way
but i also
was really wanting to to be a mother and
have another side of my life so
that's what i would say very good he
shows up he took his time i didn't get
married till i was 37
38 but now we have four children my
partner and i were guests
on a private jet when i was 27 or 28
years old
and when we walked onto the airplane it
was like the scene in the wizard of oz
when everything goes from black and
white to color like
people fly like this this is
unbelievable i want to fly like this and
by the time we land they were like let's
start a private jet company you know
like definitely you know so we could fly
privately
except we had no airplanes so um we went
to
a company called netjets owned by warren
buffett the 800 pound gorilla they had
600 plus airplanes in the fleet and
pitched this idea for a 25-hour
pre-paid jet card which was called
marquee jet
how did you get that interview like that
time with him
it's a crazy story you know i had a
friend of mine who
called me up and um prior to that i was
putting
experiences together for wealthy people
like
impossible to get experiences and a
friend of mine called me up and said
that he had a friend whose
daughter was turning 16 and he wanted to
do something at the christina aguilera
concert
and i happened to have a relationship
with the management company
and i got his daughter on as kind of
like a backup singer kind of thing with
the mic
off and the guy called me up after the
concert the next day she was the star of
the town you know everyone was talking
about it
and he was like i have no idea who you
are or what you do
but if you ever need anything call me
like that was amazing what you did for
my daughter and it turns out
he was the president of this company
called netjets
that owned all these airplanes so a year
later when we had this idea i was like
i think i know someone in this business
you're like the guy that we had sing his
daughter sang at the aguilera concert
and that's how we got the meeting
wow but the meeting actually when we
pitched the idea
um the meeting lasted 12 minutes and
they threw us out
and the president of netjet said and
this is almost a direct quote
he said you know cool idea but if you
think we're going to give
two kids that didn't break a thousand on
their s.a.t which
tom pissed me off i got like a 980 but
i've convinced myself i've gotten over
you
keep telling yourself you broke a
thousand um he's like i'm never giving
you guys
access to our our airplanes because the
the notion was
if we could sell and market onto their
fleet through this 25-hour
program called marquee jet that's how we
would piggyback off their airplanes
and they threw us out of the meeting and
then um we were relentless and we came
back and we
we realized that we couldn't sell this
concept through a powerpoint
because they'd seen they see a thousand
powerpoints a month
so we literally brought our own focus
group in to bring the meeting to life
and one by one the guys stood up
we had carl banks from the new york
giants and run from run dmc
and a powerful real estate mogul and
they explained that they would never buy
a fraction
what netjet was selling but they would
buy a 25-hour card if it was offered
and and that's how we ended up
solidifying the opportunity
and then to your point when we started
the company you know this is back in
2000 so there was i had no
sophisticated way to get leads i didn't
know a lot of wealthy people
and the only way that i could really
build my database or sell anybody was to
go to events
where rich people hung out so i heard
about this conference called the
ted i didn't even know what it was in
monterey california
so i flew commercial you know
transferred three flights to
drove six hours when i landed to get to
ted to try to
pitch this idea to anyone that would
listen but when i got to the ted
conference
it was like fort knox everybody had
credentials double credentials and i had
nothing
and they wouldn't let me anywhere near
the venue so i went to the local coffee
shop
and just trying to figure out how i'm
gonna get in or sneak in or
get someone to get me in or get access
and i realized like every hour or two
everyone with credentials was walking
into
the coffee shop and they were buying
lattes and muffins and lattes and
muffins and lattes and muffins so the
next morning
i woke up at at five o'clock and i went
to the coffee shop and i bought every
single muffin
that they had i took all the inventory
out of the shop i'm like
i'll take all your muffins they gave me
like 80 muffins and i was sitting and
then when the first wave
of ted attendees you know broke for
their break and they came one of the
customers said um you know
can i have a latte and a muffin and the
guy said well i'll give you a latte but
we're all out of muffins
and when he was walking out i said
excuse me sir you know look i i happen
to have an extra muffin
i actually have 800 of them you know but
if you want a muffin
um you can have one of my muffins he's
like no get out of here so does it
realize that he starts well what do you
do what are you doing here we started
having a conversation and he said you
know do you mind if i join you and i
you know my only thought was like you
are qualified to buy a card you can join
me
and he was my first sale he was my first
sale
a guy who owned a company that sold it
to ebay and
that was the start of the adrenaline
rush of
okay let me try to crack this code of
you know
how we can build this thing with um not
a big database
[Music]
if you want to know these seven rich
people habits that you need to try
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there if you get a
chance to go and to learn about the real
world with a great firm
you should do that if you can help
others you will feel great
the more you can help the more
intelligently you can help